[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this
is
please clear the aisles and take your
seats so we can start
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you think you should give up our
seats in the back
[Applause]
married
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
faculty
colleagues
families
friends and students
i'm delighted to welcome you to the
321st commencement of yale university
and to the 161st
anniversary of the year in which yale
conferred its first
and the nation's first phd degree
today we celebrate your accomplishments
as scholars and researchers
and we award the degrees earned by your
dedication to the advancement of human
knowledge
we're extremely proud of what you have
achieved in your time at yale and we
thank you for your contributions to your
field
congratulations to you all
to begin today's ceremony i first wish
to recognize those graduate students and
faculty who received prizes at
yesterday's convocation ceremony
your programs list the student academic
prizes
this time i ask all student prize
winners and their advisors who are
present to stand so that we can thank
the advisors for their guidance and
congratulate the students on their
achievement prize winners please stand
each year the graduate mentor awards
celebrate faculty members who have been
outstanding teachers and advisors of
graduate students the four faculty
members who received the award this year
exemplify the many important qualities
to which all graduate teachers should
aspire
at this time i ask our mentor prize
winners in attendance to stand so that
we can recognize their excellence
do you have anyone here
these four faculty represent all the
professors and instructors who have
helped all of you navigate graduate
school
you have also been supported by many
others on campus whose labor and loyalty
contribute to make yale the
distinguished university it is
let me name just a few of yale's
employees beyond faculty who stand at
the heart of yale and when we when i'm
finished we can thank them all
the universities custodial and
maintenance staff make eel look
beautiful and keep us in good condition
all year round
the hospitality staff feed us at
commencement and throughout the year the
clerical and technicals staff conduct
the university's business with acumen
and dispatch and the managerial and
professional staff direct and administer
our departments and schools
and specifically the staff of the
graduate school of arts and sciences
sustains the institution within which
yale graduate education thrives for all
these wonderful women and men of yale i
ask you for your recognition through
applause from students friends and
family alike
finally and separately i also ask you to
acknowledge the superb musical abilities
of our organist mr phillip balkan one of
our many accomplished students at yale
college who is playing on one of the
world's great pipe organs here in
woolsey hall
now just a few words to our graduating
students
candidates for the um the phd m phil and
master's degrees before we begin the
honor of conferring your diplomas
i know for many of you
getting to this graduation has not been
easy especially the last couple of years
but you have prevailed
you have taken advantage of of all yale
graduate school offers you as you
pursued your studies and scholarly
research
during your time with us you have
learned the way that the way of research
and scholarship is neither straight nor
smooth
a line of inquiry may take you nowhere
and months of work may bear no fruit
an experiment could go awry and you
could find yourself back at square one
graduate study takes inspiration but
also hard work and especially
perseverance and determination
learning to continue in the face of
challenges characterizes the ability to
do advanced research and the fact that
you sit here today means you have
learned that lesson
you have overcome all the obstacles that
stood in your way and completed your
studies in triumph
today
you leave yale as thinkers
explorers
curators teachers and you also leave
with a set of skills that equip you for
a variety of careers
you are innovative and critical thinkers
problem solvers leaders team players and
effective communicators poised to launch
fulfilling careers
whatever direction you choose to apply
your skills of advanced learning
let your accomplishments inspire you
to tackle new challenges with the
confidence that you have the skill to
navigate all difficulties
as a young graduate student you are
given the opportunity to contribute to
society
sorry i should have said as a yale
graduate you are you can contribute to
society
and to make a difference in your field
of study as you go forth
i hope that you will also stay engaged
and in touch with us as alumni and
considering consider mentoring those who
follow in your footsteps
it has been my privilege to lead the
graduate school's efforts to provide you
with the environment in which you grew
into the scholars you are today
i'm proud of all that you have
accomplished and excited to see what you
will do next congratulations
and now we will award the graduate
degrees
we will call the graduates to stage by
the department or program in which they
have earned their degrees
for those students receiving more than
one degree all diplomas will be awarded
together
dean yasmina bashirovich will read the
citations
please come forward as your name is
called
to grant to congratulate the degree
recipients
you may be joined at the front of the
stage by by faculty members from your
department or program
and please everyone applause applaud as
often as possible
dean bashirovic
is this yours here yes
okay
let me just
for the degrees in african-american
studies doctor of philosophy
bianca dang
for the degrees in african studies
masters of arts
charlotte marie bendarski
[Applause]
edward jerome hendrickson
thomas albert madre
[Applause]
ano jose codua
for the degrees in american studies
doctor of philosophy
kristen ann harkins
[Applause]
for the degrees in anthropology doctor
of philosophy
george buba yuga
elizabeth burke
let's see
three mack fong
for the degrees in applied physics
doctor of philosophy
mary lou padlon bailey
[Applause]
masters of science
very chain
[Applause]
andrew james bill nielsen
for the degrees in archaeological
studies masters of arts
min ju choi
[Applause]
aaron and laura hazel kuhn
j lynn leggett
elizabeth warner
[Applause]
for the degree
in architecture doctor of philosophy
david turturo
for the degrees in astronomy doctor of
philosophy
melania rice
[Applause]
for the degrees in cell biology
doctor of
philosophy jacob andrew culver
ekaterina strava
cc yang
[Applause]
for the degrees in cellular and
molecular physiology doctor of
philosophy
matthew alice
[Music]
genuinely
for the degrees in chemistry doctor of
philosophy
omar mustafa belle
danielle confer
matthew ryan espinoza
olivia francis gaither
robert donald hale
how li huang
maria elena leosi
[Applause]
foreign
ethan parrott
evan perez
crystal reese
[Applause]
chanel shillingford
[Applause]
jacob spees
elizabeth stone
gentao
martin dominic
[Applause]
masters of science
isaiah aguilar
jose vergara penzone
natalie williams
for the degrees in comparative
literature doctor of philosophy
victoria and bana
[Applause]
vanessa gobbins
javier lee
[Applause]
for the degrees in computational biology
and bioinformatics doctor of philosophy
guan nan gong
hussain marsein
yishwanye
[Applause]
xiaolong you
can you show
for the degrees in computer science
doctor of philosophy
william hallihan
[Applause]
christopher harsha
[Applause]
bohu
[Applause]
[Music]
master of science
christopher kai
king schweinsteil
[Applause]
hendang
you holding
[Applause]
yarugong
[Applause]
theotor hag
[Applause]
ciao gang wang
[Applause]
yuji
hi peng lee
[Applause]
joe young lee
[Applause]
liang
zhang sheng lin
jo wei lin
[Applause]
genji liu
[Applause]
yifan liu
arjun vijay nayer
muhammad yabuz zumali
where is she paying
[Applause]
you elan shank
see you song
hi how son
[Applause]
tank
[Applause]
one
[Applause]
when
juan pablo
jay babu
[Applause]
hans xiao
[Applause]
yang
[Applause]
tong you yang
derek jamingay
king you
bow xiao
[Applause]
d1 zoo
[Applause]
you shin zhu
for the degrees in earth and planetary
sciences the doctor of philosophy
daniel admond gaskell
jang gong
your kim catching off
yantau luo
master of philosophy
[Applause]
for the degrees in east asian languages
and literatures doctor of philosophy
you and bye
changly
[Music]
for the degrees in a station studies
masters of arts
ethan
glenn barcelo
jonathan bertram chiu yi chan
seeming chan
jrong fan
tyler james hayward
[Applause]
see you pan
brenda ray and tan
sabrina gene williams
[Applause]
shui chen yang
chloe young
[Music]
for the degrees in ecology and
evolutionary biology doctor of
philosophy
alejandro damian serrano
master of science diego ellis soto
for the degree in economics doctor of
philosophy
julianne arambuyu
[Music]
julian
nathan earl barker
paola andrea calvo
robert john finlay
[Applause]
jonathan thomas hawkins
kuhn kwon
[Applause]
he
luca perdoni
surav sinha
[Applause]
j he's song
xiao chuan shang
[Applause]
for the degrees in engineering and
applied science
in the program of biomedical engineering
doctor of philosophy
andrew eric sharp berentine
[Applause]
margaret elise bullock
[Applause]
tai chan
[Applause]
zachary ryan connor d martin
[Applause]
jeanette galen cressel
minsoo kwang
[Applause]
assad
samantha rosano
[Applause]
how shang
master of science
yinan chang
chiang when kevin who
aaron spencer matthias
[Applause]
aurelie motron
[Applause]
c c way
in the program of chemical and
environmental engineering doctor of
philosophy
alicia yi chan
[Applause]
uri roy gabinet
molly kathleen groon
omar caboose imran
rodrigo bento rebukas
[Applause]
shu shenzhou
in the program of electrical engineering
doctor of philosophy
shu wayne dang
[Applause]
rayleigh
zhang
[Applause]
joshua bryan surya
yihang yang
in the program of mechanical engineering
material science doctor of philosophy
walter gatlier bircher
leave
corey wen
[Applause]
joshua gorgeous pondick
dylan shah
[Applause]
nalima sharma
john durkin trido
ali yavar
for the degrees in english literature
language and literature doctor of
philosophy samuel james huber
shane mcgregor
brandon adam menke
sarah and robbins
for the degrees in environment doctor of
philosophy
adam zachary andes arietta
kira alexandra pratz
mario alipio soriano
[Applause]
for the degrees in european and russian
studies masters of arts
georgie bujalage
ning yuan chan
[Applause]
zachary klaus cho
megan elizabeth ford
gabriel marvin simon rum
[Applause]
for the degrees in experimental
pathology doctor of philosophy
christopher william anderson
jostling fangy chen
samuel robert kerr
megan kathleen mcgeary
for the degrees in film and media
studies doctor of philosophy tadas
bhagnavicius
leanna hirschfeld crone
[Applause]
for the degrees in french doctor of
philosophy
chandler marie abshire
[Applause]
doyle david calhoun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
richard riddick
[Applause]
for the degrees in genetics doctor of
philosophy
cindy marisa barish
[Applause]
juan calli laurie
[Applause]
kimberly nicole griffith
alison driscoll cookersberger
alexandra elizabeth mccall garfinkel
stephen pannier
[Applause]
paul renault
yin you
for the degrees in germanic languages
and literature doctor of philosophy
cecilia sebastian
[Applause]
for the degrees in history doctor of
philosophy
ricardo jose alvarez
oh pimentel excuse me
lyanna christine demarco
anna dancing
[Applause]
kelly goodman
hannah greenwald
amanda joyce hall
[Applause]
charlotte keyshell
[Applause]
marie mary nye
bennett haley parton
samuel john siverson
[Applause]
naomi sussman
vince velosi
masters of arts
victor babinski
leah crap
olivia mossages
julian married reinhardt
wolfstein schooler
ella starkman heinz
olivia marionyan
[Applause]
for the degrees in history of art doctor
of philosophy
contractor
philippe halbert
[Applause]
mohit manahar
[Applause]
shweta raghu
[Applause]
andrew peter vickland welcomed
for the degrees in immunobiology doctor
of philosophy yi yoon chao
tyler rice
[Music]
camila
robles ortiza
how shoe
yes in young
for the degrees in interdepartmental
neuroscience program doctor of
philosophy
gabriela maria bosque ortiz
catina constantina calacos
danielle benjamin early
[Applause]
noah golan
okay
gonzalez
sharif ismail kronmer
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
for the degrees in international and
development economics master of arts
soha fatima ahmed
swankita rajiv arora
manu biniwal
[Applause]
hurry
valerie chuang
royal chan
[Applause]
patty
[Applause]
chong
[Applause]
harriet jane cross
[Applause]
karan deryanani daryanani
[Applause]
[Applause]
kumar
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
mohammed
[Applause]
xiao
[Applause]
rao
[Applause]
vaishnavi sinha
vanessa 10 c1
[Applause]
lakshmi swanimantan
andrei tang
shimang guang
aging wu
for the degrees in investigative
medicine doctor of philosophy
marcorto mori
dennis shone
stephane zebel
yuzhank
for the degrees in linguistics doctor of
philosophy sarah babinski
josh phillips
[Applause]
muy jang
[Applause]
for the degrees in management doctor of
philosophy
sa yao liu
[Applause]
reading die
raul guriwara
david kwon
[Applause]
jingling
guy voice
[Applause]
for the degrees in mathematics doctor of
philosophy
aaron thomas wright calderon
yakir mosh forman
kratos sarkar
alex salinger
over
here for the degrees in medieval studies
masters of art
emma olsen
julian zumbach
[Applause]
for the degrees in microbiology doctor
of philosophy
leon lee
john hen park
[Applause]
for the degrees in molecular biophysics
and biochemistry doctor of philosophy
dahiana aries escaola
[Music]
[Applause]
josie evelyn bircher
[Applause]
megan rose brady
[Music]
sachita ganesha
for the degrees in molecular cellular
and developmental biology doctor of
philosophy
emma tong korcran
michael chan morrow
[Applause]
javier fortio
[Applause]
kumar
renee rhodes vasco
lauren nicole
winkler shang wu
[Applause]
for the degrees in music
doctor of philosophy
abrahamian
clifton boyd
jacqueline helson gergis
[Applause]
alexandra renee kravitz
for the degrees in near eastern
languages and civilizations doctor of
philosophy
kayla dang
[Applause]
for the degrees in nursing doctor of
philosophy
shu yuan huang
[Applause]
for the degrees in pharmacology
doctor of philosophy
michael joseph bond
[Applause]
courtney mccall smith
[Applause]
for the degrees in philosophy doctor of
philosophy
brian david
[Applause]
leah aurelia schroeder
rebecca elizabeth wallets
[Applause]
for the degrees in physics doctor of
philosophy
kelly marie bacchus
daniel berkowitz
[Applause]
emma grace castilla
paul edward fonto
[Applause]
conor han
emily kuhn
sang jai lee
[Applause]
michael henry oliver
luis elia saldana santistebn
[Applause]
andrew shem
[Music]
christopher wang
[Applause]
javanese
[Applause]
for the degrees in political science
doctor of philosophy
angela delbert
[Applause]
sophie jacobson
constantine mississippi amanda
tori lynn mcmurdo
darren king juana
[Applause]
over here
stephanie almeida nevin
eli kevin rao
james sandquist
[Applause]
for the degrees in psychology
doctor of philosophy chi lin
[Applause]
paola adriozola
lauren michelle patrick
[Applause]
este adriana rubin thomas
colin stanton
[Applause]
for the degrees in public health doctor
of philosophy
hannah angelic
canada suranga
[Applause]
low
alyssa charles for pia
miley thayer phillips
brian thompson
[Applause]
phoebe tran
elizabeth bennett white
yi liang zhang
master of science
anandang
[Applause]
chiang khan
hugo hey
[Applause]
king
lisa kim
jesuan lee
shield mainly
she angle
beijing meng
[Applause]
lauren pistol
[Applause]
yivanshi
[Applause]
by hand song
[Applause]
son
[Applause]
[Applause]
wang
[Applause]
you swan wang
[Applause]
find your way
[Applause]
[Applause]
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
chang
[Applause]
mijo
[Applause]
[Applause]
for the degrees in religious studies
doctor of philosophy
daniel eastman anne
[Applause]
liana danani
[Applause]
stephanie mcabee
wendy mullett
cody
masselman
[Applause]
sarah zaiger
[Applause]
for the degrees in renaissance studies
doctor of philosophy
thomas santamaria
[Applause]
for the degrees in slavic languages and
literatures doctor of philosophy
anna berdinski
sean blank
anastasia christina
[Applause]
for the degrees in sociology
doctor of philosophy
patrice collins
jacob darshan
because kalisha the sources figures
[Applause]
dana hayward
masters of art
jesse dong
[Applause]
for the degrees in spanish and
portuguese masters of art
kate tyra olivier
[Applause]
for the degrees in statistics masters of
art
justin eli cabot miller
laura herron
donald kenny
jeffrey martin
[Music]
ivanid cowers a car
for the degrees in statistics and data
science
doctor of philosophy
parker holzer
[Applause]
soham jhana
gandlin's song
[Applause]
masters of science aditya biswas
[Applause]
john len chen
shi yao gong
shio ro liang
jose antonio sidawi gali
heeda sebastian verholt
[Applause]
yi yang
[Applause]
fang bing shu
tialu shu
see pay jou
[Applause]
masters of art
yi yoon chan
[Applause]
candice the journal
so every year for various reasons it
happens that some students are not able
to sit with their departments and come
forward for their diplomas in the usual
order
so now we award the final degrees which
in some cases may not appear in the
program
doctor of philosophy
gabriel enrique pitazorn
[Applause]
oh i should
arthur bank in english
[Applause]
muhammad hamad khan
in biomedical engineering
jung in immunobiology
[Applause]
joseph suleiman in physics
[Applause]
william thompson in physics
[Applause]
cassandra jane clark in public health
[Applause]
margaret cyra picardo in public health
benjamin sleighton masters of arts in
african-american studies
thomas schwartz masters of arts in
history
[Applause]
anjana
international in development development
economics
[Applause]
thank you joe international and
developmental economics
[Applause]
master of science
public health kung rang huang
[Applause]
xining yang
[Applause]
international in development economics
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're checking
i think we're done sorry
thank you yasmina that was terrific
parker henry applied physics
[Music]
thank you dean pascherovic
all right
as i call out each of the degrees we've
conferred today
please stand up if that's the degree you
got and remain standing well i ask
everyone here to congratulate you master
of arts
master of science
master of philosophy
doctor of philosophy
[Applause]
[Music]
degree recipients please remain standing
everyone else can have a seat again
we like
in the graduate school we like to
recognize that the commitment of time
effort and attention
required to achieve an advanced degree
is only possible with the participation
and support of not only your professors
and classmates but also your families
and friends
therefore i invite all of our degree
recipients to turn and acknowledge the
roles played by others in the the
achievements we are celebrating together
today
[Music]
okay now you can be seated
new alumni of the graduate school
you have been an integral part of one of
civilization's highest inventions the
research university where the mission is
creation of new knowledge and passing it
along to to next generations
as you've learned finding new knowledge
new truth about our world is not a
solitary endeavor you have lived within
an extensive academic network in which
you can follow your curiosity rigorously
test your ideas benefit from critique
and go forward in an unexpected
direction
you have learned that a convincing
argument backed by evidence from primary
sources or well-controlled experiments
will stand up to careful scrutiny and
importantly pave the way for the next
person to take another step savor this
rejoice in this
it is a rare privilege to possess this
experience and its teachings can be
applied throughout your life
it is now your responsibility to spread
that knowledge beyond the university
wherever your future brings you
share what you have learned and what you
will learn
our world needs to know true things
backed by hard-won evidence now
more than ever
be the source of truth in the midst of
confusion and misinformation
take what you have learned at yale and
make the world a better place
i also ask you to reflect on the people
who helped you make it through graduate
school to find your career path
as you benefited from being mentored
consider being a mentor yourself
think about sharing your knowledge and
experience
with upcoming students through the
graduate student alumni association or
by signing up to be part of cross campus
our portal for bringing alumni and
current students together for networking
and career support
you may not realize how much your
experience can already be of benefit to
others
so as we conclude
uh please remain in your seats until the
platform party recesses from the
auditorium
then please process out using the side
exits
uh they're over here
and over here so there's
on on the sides
onto college street or by nikki plaza
please do not exit through the rotunda
because the school of public health is
waiting out there to come in for their
ceremony
to that end please exit quickly so that
the next ceremony can begin on time our
ushers will assist you in finding your
way out
graduates
you your friends and families together
with the faculty and staff who are with
us are invited to a reception
immediately following the conclusion of
this ceremony in the calkins courtyard
at the
mcdougall center i hope you can join us
on behalf of all of yale
congratulations
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you